scp 682 versus scp-117  the hard to destroy reptile versus the  perfect multi-tool but can this  ultra-convenient and somewhat vampiric  gadget finally macgyver this nasty  lizard out of existence the foundation  started with a sample test using tissue  extracted from 682's back and a d-class  in charge of holding the multi-tool the  test looked promising 117 produced a  number of pneumatic hammers and pounded  the 682 tissue sample into a fine slurry  then disintegrated the slurry into  nothingness with particle beam weaponry  leaving the d-class it was being handled  by with an almost deadly mineral  deficiency however as you can probably  guessed the test against the whole 682  lizard wasn't so successful rather than  attacking 682 117 produced a device that  teleported itself and the d-class using  it away killing the d-class in the  process test failed